okay should we give this okay now seen
some X's around I think I've seen one
and a half right answers um let's go
through shall we
what's the duty to the inside because
what's the derivative of the outside
it's one over so I'm just gonna skip the
water bar and I'm just gonna write it
down the bottom what is on the
denominator what's the derivative of
sine inverse it's that it's the square
root of 1 minus ya and then usually we
have x squared there right but this time
my inside function is sine okay now just
be really careful here right now what am
I gonna follow with me cos x odd one
minus sine squared is equal to cos
squared so that looks to me like cause
which looks like one which is wrong why
well it's okay now all right now this is
important right I'll draw this in a
second but I hope you remember roughly
what this looks like okay so you know
enough about what it looks like to know
the way kind of right I know right
actually where exactly half right right
but where did the other half go what
would the other part of the answer be
you'll be minus one right now where did
the -1 go where was the problem that was
my problem there's a problem here what's
the problem
okay is the problem at this point start
wrong at this point I'm okay that's
alright I've just done the tribute from
here to here I'm still okay right
because I've just don't want - sense for
this cos squared that's always true okay
but this is where it breaks down okay
now what should I have written instead
if this is like you know what's your
role what am I missing
now you can do it a couple of different
ways I would suggest the best way to
write what's missing is to put an
absolute value sign there
okay because this is important for us so
let me rub off now the reason why I
think an absolute value sign is better
than some of you are suggesting I should
slap them plus or minus at the front
okay
the plus or minus is tricky plus or
minus you get your do you solve a
quadratic right and yeah I hear my
answers plus or minus whatever okay but
it doesn't tell you when it's one answer
and when it's the other okay whereas we
know this is going to simplify out it's
positive one sometimes and sometimes
only and negative one at other times so
I should know when each one is each
right so plus or minus is kind of not
enough information right so from here I
want to remember what does absolute
value mean go back to definitions from
the end of last year this is equal to
two things okay let's take the positive
case first it should be cos x or cos x
for what values namely when cos x is
positive okay if the number inside there
is positive I just give you back the
number so this is one okay if on the
other hand what you have is cos x being
negative
then you flip it around
it's those cases where you get negative
context now that's a little more helpful
okay so you can see how I'm saying more
than just possible minus one whenever
okay I'm plus or minus one in these
specific places and this is really
helpful to us because how do we graph
this last time we're kind of um we were
very thoughtful where we just like
values plot points see what happens okay
but this is meaningful right let's think
about this because we know what cos x
looks like right let me graph cos x and
let me suggest to you to draw out a nice
wide set of axes here well it's cos x
look like something like this right
feels better than my last one just okay
right now what is telling us this graph
it's derivative when class X is positive
the derivative is 1 so it's increasing
okay so look at all the places where
cause X is greater than 0 right so for
instance right in between here
what's this domain what are the two
values on either side yeah this is minus
PI - it's a plan - right which is what
we got before ok so that's why you're
getting it increasing during this domain
ok but when I transfer over to this side
here why why did it just you know bounce
ok and we were like that's kind of like
saying it goes up and down but that's
not really the reason this is the real
reason right this is what happens to the
derivative because of this absolute
value signs right so in this domain
between PI and 2 and 3 plan - the
derivative is negative 1 which is why it
comes back yeah okay now you go from
here to here cos x is positive again so
that's why your gradient is 1 and
there's where we get this up-and-down
shape from ok so it wasn't just oh
that's kind of funny and that's what the
values do when you're testing that
calculus shows you why okay all right
now I want to give you one more example
and I'm gonna get again you to think
about it first and because we've gone
through this trick hopefully you'll be a
little more mindful of it this time and
I won't need to show you through it yeah
the blue is this actual graph right yeah
so we've these derivatives I wanted to
see well what does that say about the
graph and it gives it this kind of
absolute value like sort of characters
there because this is um this is the
same thing that you get for the absolute
value of x the gradient is 1 sometimes
when it's positive then it's minus 1
well I'm graphing the actual function
not the derivative so if I were to graph
the derivative what would it look like I
guess it would well let's see okay so
you know give me in this domain here my
sorry that's um what's Pilate ooh that's
at one point five seven so I should be
lower than that it looked like that
there's my there's my one right and then
like you said at that point there I
don't know what the derivative is
and then down here it will continue data
- why don't you get the idea so yes the
derivative would have closed okay okay
so sorry it's a function I want you have
a look at now was this now some of you
have been working your head might
recognize it okay it certainly has some
some suspicious characteristics about it
okay
all the same I'd like you to work out
what its derivatives ears and then off
the derivative do you notice anything
unusual and can we graph it on the basis
of that okay so there's the function
give it go